Now it's time for
you to update your weather app.
Using the cache then network strategy,
I want you first to modify the get
forecast method in your app.js file
to get data from the cache and
kick off a request to the weather API.
Then, update the service worker to
check the URL being requested, and
if it's a request to the weather API,
cache the response in the data
cache before returning it.
Make sure you use
progressive techniques here.
Using feature detection to
determine if the cache's object
is available in the global scope.
And makes sure that if the network
returns before the cache,
the cache doesn't clobber
the network data.
When you've completed this step,
your app should now work offline.
Try loading the app then
turn off your network and
your web server to see if it does.
You can compare your app to the link
in the instructor notes below
to make sure it works exactly the same.
And don't forget to try your
app in multiple browsers.
How does it work in Firefox?
Safari?
Etc.
If you try and load this in a browser
that doesn't support service workers,
it may not work offline, but
it should work just fine when online.